>> Laura: TONIGHT WE'RE KICKING
OFF THE FIRST IN A SERIES WE'LL
CALL MR. FETTERMAN GOES TO
WASHINGTON.
NEWLY ELECTED SENATE MEMBERS HAD
THEIR ORIENTATION AND
PENNSYLVANIA'S JOHN FETTERMAN
WAS ALMOST UNRECOGNIZABLE IN A
SUIT.
NOW, THE MASSIVE MARION ET WAS
GREETED AS A CONCURRING HERO BY
HIS NEW MASTERS.
>> WHOA.
WHY ARE YOU IN HERE?
>> Laura: BUT IT WASN'T ALL
BREEZY AS SHREK MACE HIS FIRST
TREK THROUGH THE SENATE HE WAS
ASKED ABOUT HIS TRADEMARK LOOK.
WHEN THE REPORTER TWEETED HE
DIDN'T GET REPLY TO THE QUESTION
THEY CAME IN AND SAID HE'S STILL
RECOVERING FROM A STREAK AND HAS
PROBLEMS WITH AUDITORY AND THE
WAY YOU YELL WON'T WORK HERE.
BUT BEYOND THE PESKY REPORTERS
FETTERMAN HAS ANOTHER POTENTIAL
CHALLENGER TO KEEP HIS EYE ON
AND IT'S ONE OF HIS CLOSEST
FRIENDS, WELL, HIS WIFE, GISELE.
DURING THE CAMPAIGN THERE WERE
SUGGESTIONS SHE WAS REALLY
PULLING ALL THE STRINGS BECAUSE
SHE GAVE SPEECHES, DID
INTERVIEWS AND SOME EVEN MUSED
THAT SHE WAS ANGLING TO REPLACE
HIM IF HE SHOULD WIN.
WELL, TONIGHT WE HAVE OUR HANDS
ON TWO PIECES OF EVIDENCE THAT
SHOW THAT SHE MIGHT BE SLOWLY
PUSHING HIM OUT OF THE FRAME AT
LEAST.
NOW, THE FIRST PICTURE SHOWS
THEM POSING IN FRONT OF HIS NEW
OFFICE.
AS YOU CAN SEE HIS RIGHT ARM IS
CHOPPED OUT.
NOT TERRIBLY EGREGIOUS, COME ON.
UNTIL YOU SEE PART OF A LARGER
NARRATIVE DEVELOPING.
THE NEXT PICTURE SHOWS THE
FETTERMANS WITH FELLOW
PENNSYLVANIA SENATOR BOB CASEY
AND HIS WIFE.
AS YOU CAN SEE HERE, THE TOP OF
HIS HEAD IS CUT OFF.
SO HOW LONG UNTIL HE'S CROPPED
OUT OF THE PICTURES COMPLETELY?
OKAY.
NOW, WE'RE GOING TO CONTINUE TO
MONITOR THIS IN OUR ONGOIN